in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Ryan
and Michelle are with us hey guys how
are ya welcome welcome where you guys
from
we're from Milwaukee Wisconsin welcome
to Nashville fun good to have you so
you're here to do your debt-free scream
yes and how much have you paid off we
paid off $65,000 and how long did that
take 19 months way to go making what
range of income during that time we
started at about a hundred and with over
time we got to about 120 way to go what
do you guys do for a living um I work
for the United States Postal Service and
I work for food packaging company cool
very cool well good to have you guys
welcome what kind of debt was a 65,000
it was a little bit of everything we had
student loans car loans medical debts
credit cards yes yeah pretty much a
little bit everything happened how long
you guys been married seven years okay
so you start out with a bunch of debt
and just kept adding okay yeah so what
happened nineteen months ago that woke
you up you said I got to change this um
you know I really think it started when
we had our daughter Ava four years ago
at that point we knew we should probably
commit to you know stop using debt stop
using credit cards but we just didn't
really have a plan for getting out of
the debt that we were already in um it
wasn't until I stumbled onto your book
the Total Money Makeover read it in an
afternoon and was just all in yeah very
cool well good so how you just stumbled
into it it just I did yeah I wasn't
looking for it I just happened to see it
at a store and thought you know you know
let me get this and read this and see if
you know it'll work for us and well it
has so she gets all hard on this book
Ryan what were you saying um well I kind
of was tired of being in debt and not
being able to really do anything and
when we would do it we put it all on
credit cards so it wasn't hard to talk
you into this no not at all okay and so
you got an attack mode decided to knock
off the debts mm-hmm
did you sell anything we sold little
things around the house but nothing big
big thing was you just got on the budget
and yeah cut the end cut the lifestyle
yes oh yeah overtime it's a great place
to go when you're broke don't worry yeah
very cool
well congratulations you guys so when
people hear that you paid off $65,000 in
nineteen months and they say how in the
world how'd you do that what do you tell
them what the what the what do you tell
them the keys are getting out of that
budget and absolutely the budget that's
sticking to it mm-hmm was a hard to
stick to I mean yeah we have times yeah
we had a couple you know disagreements
here and there and I what was the best
fighter
I think the grocery budget for what and
it wasn't me it was more I'd rather like
eat you know beans and rice rice and
beans and he was like okay and this is
getting a little old yeah five times a
week kind of all them really I hear ya
you know you never want to see those
things or smell them again finding that
balance yeah okay so you had a little
yeah I was like would you please buy
some food yeah yeah I love it that's fun
very cool
so you scratched and clawed wasn't worth
all the trouble oh my goodness yes how
does it feel now you feel great about
yourself yes such a relief it really is
so on and and your kids are with you
their nature what Ava and for uh-huh and
Jackson who's three Ava and Jackson okay
and have they been practicing their debt
free scream with you oh yes yeah very
cool good good
all right you guys well I love it Ryan
and Michelle Ava and Jackson $65,000
paid off in nineteen months making a
hundred to one hundred and twenty a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream don't even three
yeah
way to go guys way to go a vibin started
in Florida countdown since she's four
that's perfect that's good I love it
well done very well done excellent proud
of you guys
excellent job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind